hello and welcome to the great energy
transition a new series from
Intelligence Squared in partnership with
Cummings this series is all about
bringing together leading voices to
discuss the big questions around the
environment and energy and the journey
to Net Zero I'm Helen chesky I'm your
host and in our first two events this is
the third one of three we covered two
big topics what's happening between now
and 2030 to achieve Net Zero and what
needs to happen between 2030 and 2050 to
achieve Net Zero and in this third and
final event we'll be discussing the role
of corporations in the energy transition
now there are plenty of big questions
here do corporations lead or do they
follow do they hold themselves to higher
standards because they can or do they do
the minimum required by the government
to stay competitive or about training
the workforce choosing goals and metrics
and stepping away from or towards
products that could make a really big
difference once they're out in the world
we will be dealing with all all of that
and obviously corporations are important
you know they've always been engines of
growth and Innovation but perhaps in the
past the fundamental aims are a little
bit simpler you know make money grow be
around in 10 years time but this time
it's different now we Face a huge
Collective challenge this energy
transition and Society needs
corporations to act as partners on a
huge Mission rather than winners and
losers in these perhaps more traditional
arguments about
um regulation and Taxation and
increasingly what corporations do is
visible to the rest of us accountability
is changing and so it's not enough just
to act you have to be seen to act so
corporations have a huge role to play in
this and we will be discussing all of
that and here's how it's going to work
we'll get some perspective on our topic
for today from each of our three expert
speakers and their perceptions on how
corporations are changing and what more
is needed and then we'll have a wider
discussion with our panel and after that
you get to ask your questions now the
way to do that is to find the Q a button
which will be somewhere on the screen or
device in front of you
um to type in your question there if
you'd like your name and where you're
from to be read out do please include it
with the question and importantly you
can be asking those questions right the
way through so you can start right now
if you'd like and I'll be reminding you
as we go along
um to be adding your questions in there
so so as soon as a question occurs to
you do please put it in the in the Q a
box and if you are active on social
media do uh tweet or LinkedIn or
whatever social media you're using these
days the hashtag is hashtag iq2 for
Intelligence Squared so do feel free to
talk about what's going on with all um
on those on those forums
okay so let's meet our speakers for
today we have three first up we have
Jennifer Rumsey who is the president and
CEO of coming zinc and she's currently
overseeing the Strategic Direction
growth initiatives and Global operations
for this uh company which is 103 years
old so that's quite a responsibility uh
it's the world's largest independent
manufacturer of engines and related
Technologies and and she's served in
several leadership positions across the
company so she knows it extremely well
next up we have Jillian tet who is the
chairman of the U.S editorial board and
U.S editor at large at the financial
times she has written many books
including fool's gold and anthro vision
a new way to see business in and life
she holds a PHD in social anthropology
from the University of Cambridge and her
work has been widely recognized by lots
of organizations uh various prizes
including just as one example columnist
business and journalist journalist and
business journalist of the year at the
British press Awards in in 2014 and then
finally our third contributor is Jason
bordoff he's an American politics energy
policy expert and researcher who works
at the intersection of Economics energy
and the environment and also National
Security he's the founding director of
the center on global energy policy at
Columbia University and the co-founding
dean of the Columbia climate school and
he's previously served as Special
Assistant to President Barack Obama and
senior director for energy and climate
change on the staff of the National
Security Council so as you can see we
have some people who have a lot to say
about this topic with a huge amount of
experience to contribute so let's get
started
um and and Jen let's start with you uh
just for those who don't know so much
about cummins or perhaps about your role
could you just tell us a little bit
about yourself
yeah I'd love to First hello everyone
great to be with you thank you Helen for
um for leading this this important
discussion today uh as you said Cummins
is 103 year old company who got our
start in diesel engines and innovating
diesel technology and really making it
the standard power uh provider for
Trucking um and today we serve customers
around the world we have more than 60
000 employees around the world
um in commercial and Industrial
applications so our products go into
applications that are at the heart of
the con economy critical to our daily
lives and also contribute meaning
meaningfully to CO2 emissions and Global
CO2 emissions so as as CEO my focus is
on taking this 103 year old company that
started in diesel and really being a
part of helping our industry decarbonize
and reach zero and it's something that I
look forward to the conversation about
because I do you think that companies
play an important role in in leading and
driving at this very important time in
our world
and and just very briefly because
obviously we'll be talking a lot about
this how you know the company has your
company has committed to reaching that
Zero by 2050 which for a for a company
that was entirely fossil fuel based is
is a big ask so just briefly how are you
going to achieve I mean what does it
when a corporation is looking at that
like how do you even go about that yeah
so so comments has long embraced uh
stakeholder model and recognizing the
importance of not only serving our
customers our investors also our
communities and our employees and so we
actually embrace Challenge and use that
challenge to drive Innovation and growth
we've done that historically as we've
reduced emissions from diesel engines
and we're really approaching the need to
decarbonize uh in a similar way we we
believe that for our industry that is so
both uh economically vital and needs to
be changed in a way that works for the
economy and also uh get to zero CO2
emissions that we do need to start
investing and advancing technologies
that get us all the way to zero and we
are doing that in our new power business
with battery electric and Fuel Cell
electric and green hydrogen Technologies
and we also believe that diesel engines
play an important role because we have
to start today we can't wait our
products get used for decades and so we
must drive reductions in engine-based
Solutions uh as a as well as develop
these diverse solutions that will serve
our applications and get all the way to
zero
great well let's let's come to Jillian
now and Jillian you've spent you know
you've had a career writing about And
discussing uh the role that corporations
play in climate change so from your
perspective like what do you think the
state of play is now when it comes to
corporations and sustainability goals
you know is it really happening and what
how much you know what should be
happening next
well it's worth stepping back for a
moment and saying that I first crashed
into this world
um shortly after the election of Donald
Trump when most journalists thought that
the only thing that really mattered that
was real news in America where I'm based
was um Trump trump and Trump and I
noticed I kept getting a lot of emails
in my inbox from companies and their PRS
talking about this thing called ESG
environmental social and governance and
sustainability
um and I deleted most of them for the
first few months because you know most
journalists are trained to think that
when companies start talking about doing
good and sustainability they're
basically doing a whole bunch of you
know corporate spin or PR Spin and
trying to bamboozle journalists
um and then after a few months I
realized actually I started listening to
the companies and concerned and the
financiers and realized actually there
was a shift in mentality going on a
Zeitgeist shift which was really about
companies trying to redefine themselves
to have a sense of purpose
um financiers trying to explain what
impact on the world the chase for
profits was actually having and also
governments running out of money to do
their development objectives and needing
to either use philanthropic cash or
corporate cash to get things done and
that was coming together to drive this
whole ESG movement to drive a
sustainability and most critically it
was driven by three things there were
three buckets of motives
um a tiny minority of companies were
doing it because they genuinely wanted
to change the world or investors and
those were people who were doing impact
investing they tend to tended to be sort
of Scandal then Pension funds and
Wealthy trust fund kids with a
conscience and stuff
um and then you had a bigger pool of
investors who wanted to do no harm to
the world and that was really what I
call the sustainability crew and then
you had an even bigger group of
companies and this is the key point but
really starting in about 2017-2018
wanted to avoid doing harm to themselves
because they'd realize that if they were
essentially seen to be polluting the
world they were in danger of losing
customers employees investors having
regulatory fines and reputational damage
so the whole drive towards environmental
issues and sustainability had flipped
from being something that was just kind
of in the doing good bucket in one tiny
Department of the company but have
become a key component of risk
management
and that really changed the whole debate
I guess that's really it's really
interesting from the point of view I
mean it's perhaps um encouraging from
the point of view of listeners who might
kind of feel helpless you know they're
just people out in the world that
actually public pressure does have an
effect on those things so perhaps that's
a note of optimism there and let's just
so we've we've gone around everyone to
get a a rounded picture of of who we've
got here let's come to Jason uh board
off now so Jason your your thing is
energy policy and and critically policy
is is not you know it the politics is
built into it right
um so how what's the interaction between
governments and corporations like in
this space like is it are they working
together at the moment and how do we
measure success
well I think ultimately we measure
success by whether emissions start going
down and so by that metric we're failing
we should remember other than a
recession or a pandemic emissions are
going up each and every year there are
some promising indicators that tell us
that might change going forward in most
recent annual Outlook that the
International Energy agency produces the
one that just came out a few weeks ago
this is the first time ever
in their Outlook that they find that
fossil fuel use peaks in the Outlook but
bear in mind the current Outlook is to
Peak and Plateau not fall at the rate
that would be necessary to come anywhere
close to climate goals like Net Zero by
2050 and to get there we're going to
need both government and and of course
the private sector I run something as
you said the center on global energy
policy with the word policy in its name
and have spent my career working in
policy because I think it's necessary
not sufficient but but necessary to get
to those goals and it shapes the playing
field uh on in which companies um
financial institutions corporations make
their decisions the energy transition
needs a whole of society buy-in it's not
going to work if Government and
corporations have an adversarial
relationship and and both have a role to
play uh we need somewhere in the order
of three to four trillion dollars a year
of investment going into clean energy
between now and 2050 to take a goal like
Net Zero seriously most of that will be
private Capital there's just not enough
public Capital uh to fund the transition
private Capital can point it in a
certain direction it can de-risk certain
new technologies or regions of the world
that can catalyze
private Capital the same with the
technologies that we're going to need
somewhere around half of the cumulative
emission reductions between now and 2050
and those Net Zero scenarios come from
technologies that are not yet available
at commercial scale we need to bring the
cost of those Technologies down in
government investment in early stage
Technologies in r d research and
development can help do that so the
private sector can then step in and and
take it from there
and so I'm interested in something that
you know that what the big recent news
in this area has been the inflation
reduction act uh the IRA which still
feels strange for a British person to
say but
um so this has been the big policy move
in the past few months um is this going
to do the job from your point of view
Jason and we'll come to
um Jillian and Jen but so is you know is
this enough and is it going to work
well it's certainly not enough but it is
a very significant step forward and it
is the by far the largest investment in
clean energy in U.S history
um there's a range of projections out
there and you should take them all with
a rather large grain of salt but the U.S
commitment is to reduce emissions around
50 by 2030 and a range of modeling
estimates show this will get us around
40 percent so there's more work to do
but but it makes a big step in in the
right direction there are a lot of
challenges to implementation and I think
that needs to be the focus now for for
all countries not just the US that is
one thing that I don't think emerged as
strongly as it could have or should have
from the U.N climate talks in Egypt is
now
taking the pledges and targets and the
ambition that came out of recent climate
talks whether it's in Paris or Glasgow
and and implementation let's actually
make sure that we're doing what we said
we would do and in the US that's going
to be difficult I mean you look at some
of the
assumptions built into the modeling
those numbers I just gave forty percent
fifty percent it assumes the inflation
reduction spending again nearly 400
billion dollars in spending is able to
increase Renewables at a rate that would
more than double the renewable capacity
in the US by 2030. that requires a lot
more transmission uh it's really hard to
build things it's hard to get permitting
it's hard to get approvals we're going
to need to reform our processes here the
way Europe is trying to do with repower
EU not just because of climate but also
now in energy security challenge we've
seen a European backlash to the
inflation reduction act because there
are elements of protectionism in it
there are elements of industrial policy
which says if you want the tax credits
you have to make sure certain activity
is done in the US or sometimes Free
Trade Agreement countries so I can go on
the list there's a range of
implementation challenges but the focus
now really has to be putting that money
to work and making sure that between now
and 2030 we can scale clean energy at a
rapid rate because it has come down and
cost a lot solar batteries they're all
much much cheaper now let's get them out
there
well um so let's Jen I'm interested in
your perspective on this on these big
policy things from government and how
they how they incentivize corporations
or how they have impacted you know
Cummins what what's it like if you're on
the receiving end of all of this
yeah well first I'll say I agree with
Jason that the the climate provisions
and the inflation reduction act are an
important step and insufficient by
themselves
um and uh we do need policy policy plays
an important role to complement what
corporations are are doing to actually
drive the level of change that's
required and really I think about it in
three dimensions there's a massive need
to build out an infrastructure to
support alternate technologies that can
reach zero emissions
you have to decarbonize that
infrastructure and cost right all three
of those are challenges we face today
and there's massive investment to build
out that infrastructure and ensure that
it's actually decarbonized if we have
charging infrastructure that is not fed
from renewable energy it's not any
better for the environment than
continuing to to burn fossil fuels and
engine so it must decarbonize and the
costs are higher you know our customers
today many of them have set
sustainability targets for themselves
and they're seeking the most
cost-effective way to achieve those
because they're running businesses uh
and these Technologies cost more today
so important provisions and the
inflation reduction act including
providing some tax credits and
incentives that help offset some of the
higher costs in the early days because
as you scale this up and and we move to
higher volume production costs will
continue to come down
um and and our view is that we can reach
um parity with the cost of internal
combustion engines over time but those
Investments to to again Drive scaling
and also continue to advance the
technology are critical as well as the
infrastructure side
and Jillian how does that kind of policy
play into how does it compare with you
you were talking about the other
incentives for uh companies to shift
their behavior do do the do the big
policy things is that a big you know if
a company was kind of heading in that
direction anyway is it more of a nudge
in the right direction or is it is it
the kick that makes them start rolling
down the slope
well I was in the camp that was
originally a bit cynical about the
inflation reduction act primarily
because it's one of the worst named
bills out there and The Branding is
Dreadful um because it really hasn't got
much to do with inflation at all and
it's not necessarily going to reduce
inflation but what it does have
underneath that totally misleading
mislabel
um is actually a lot of very very
striking measures that most of us who
are cynical journalists didn't actually
think the Biden Administration was
actually going to get done I mean most
of us didn't think the government was
going to get anything done but they did
get this done
um and the important point to stress
with this is that you know in spite of
all the signs of companies potentially
black backsliding green washing in spite
of the fact that the um climate talks in
Egypt were in many ways quite
disappointing what you have right now is
this explosion of energy and activity in
the private sector around Renewables
um you've got a lot of deal making
you've got a huge number of investment
funds with enormous amounts of money
being raised to invest in Renewables and
you have things like these incentives
for companies to get going and actually
try and install them and get the
capacity together
um and you know incentives work they
really do work
um and some of the cost reductions we've
seen in other technologies have been
remarkable and you have to hope that
it's going to occur in other areas of
the transition as well I mean the
question I always have in my mind is
whether we've seen low hanging fruit
already I mean the fact that it's now
you know often cheaper to charge your
you know electric vehicle or Tesla than
to fill it up with petrol or gas you
know was that the low-hanging fruit the
fact that you know solar wind under
thumb measure is now cheaper than other
forms of fossil fuels you know was that
the low hang fruit and I'd love to hear
Jason talk about this you know how are
you going to get the battery storage how
are you going to get all the heavy
boring geeky stuff to do with
infrastructure in place I suspect that
could be the really tough stuff going
forward but
um certainly you know the I the
inflation reduction Act is remarkable
well it is I mean the the problem with
all of this is that firstly in the way
the devil is in the detail then secondly
as you say the public perception of that
detail is often that it's just not very
sexy at all
um when you know new wind turbines might
be great but retrofitting homes isn't
um Jason I'm interested in your you know
as someone who has worked within you
know as a policy advisor to an
Administration you've seen the kind of
the sticky end of this right the
negotiations the are they actually going
to do what we want them to do you know
if a government is trying to incentivize
companies to do something what's your
experience of just could you just share
some of that experience and how whether
it's frustrating to be on the inside or
whether you feel like you can actually
get things done
well it's certainly frustrating much of
the time and I suspect that's only more
true today given how polarized our
politics is and how hard it is to get
things done but when you can get
something done
um there are a few things that can move
the needle as much as major federal
policy initiative uh certainly in a
large country like the US and I think
the inflation reduction Act is a good
example of that I think we had some big
wins in the Obama Administration like
the uh Recovery Act that was 90 billion
dollars of investment in green energy
this is several several times that but
it is uh as I said earlier now
now the challenge is implementation and
how do we make sure that we uh put this
bill to work in a way that really drives
decarbonization and as we heard already
some discussion of solar and wind or
electric vehicles and how much the cost
of those things have come down by the
way the costs are going up the last
couple of years so there is this
question now about inflation in the
clean energy sector driven by supply
chain problems the dramatic increase in
critical minerals the lithium the things
you need to make the batteries so the
components that will be needed for a
clean energy transition those have
economic and geopolitical challenges we
should come back to but of course
Renewables create electricity and
electricity is only around 20 percent of
the world's final energy consumption and
when you look at the rest of
parts of the energy system hopefully can
be electrified like maybe heating homes
or driving cars that's harder to do for
other parts of Transportation like
shipping or Aviation it's harder to do
for major parts of Industry like glass
making and fertilizer and steel and
cement so we're going to need a pretty
broad range of Technologies Renewables
will play a really important role but
we're not going to decarbonize globally
with Renewables alone and many of those
technologies have to have to advance
further and there again there's a really
important role for government and then
there's a really important role for
companies and many are making
um early commitments uh we saw this with
this this initiative called the first
movers Coalition that that came together
again in uh in Egypt at the cop this
year a group of companies that have said
were willing to pay somewhat of a
premium uh to try to make sure that
we're making commitments for how to do
some things in lower carbon ways that
admittedly are costlier today but
hopefully if we can get them to scale
we'll come down in cost and be more
affordable the way we've seen solar
costs fall 90 percent uh win win costs
fall around 70 percent battery costs
fall almost 90 percent over the last 10
15 years
so let's pick up on the the corporations
having goals uh specific goals on this
um so uh Julian you mentioned the
acronym ESG environmental social and
governance
um and you know so so it sounds great so
a corporation comes along they're like
you know I want to be a good person I
want to be seen as a good actor here are
my ESG goals
but this is a messy thing right you know
in a way part of the problem is that
money is easy to count and success in
these environmental and social things
isn't easy to count so how how do we
make sure that corporations so we'll
come in a minute to Jen and we're coming
to do about this but how how are
corporations how do we check like
where's the accountability here well the
important thing to understand is
basically the what's going on here once
you get Beyond ESG and the details of
the green transition is a really
fundamental like guys shift in companies
because in the middle of the 20th
century an economist called Milton
Friedman came out and said the company
should only care about shareholders and
that dominated the whole way that
company Executives were trained and that
investors thought about companies for
many many years
and what's that what people have not
failed to realize was that Milton
Friedman was in many way the product of
his time and he lived in an era
post-world War II when two or three
things were true which are not true
today firstly post-world War II there
was very little transparency about what
companies were doing except for
quarterly reports
um or half yearly reports most people
didn't know
um secondly people tended to assume that
it was job of government not companies
to fix big social problems because they
kind of trust the government to get
stuff done post World War II and thirdly
people had a lot of respect for leaders
and authority figures
and today what's happened is that people
don't trust government to do anything
all the surveys show that businesses
were as trusted as Government to
actually get stuff done
um and there's radical transparency in
the sense that anyone using a smartphone
can see what is happening inside
companies a lot of the time through the
Glassdoor or increasingly through
satellites tracking which companies
remitting what
um there's a real sense of transparency
and why the society doesn't really trust
authority figures anymore there's much
more sense of trust in the group so you
add that together and the what companies
are doing in response is going from this
very narrow tunnel vision I'm only going
to think about shareholders and money
and profits into thinking about what I
call lateral Vision stakeholders wider
Society it's a really fundamental
Zeitgeist because if they ignore what
Society thinks these days
um it's going to come back and bite them
that's increasingly the issue around
risk management because Society can see
and Society can complain courtesy of our
smartphones
so that's one of the key things why
companies are behaving like this because
if you want to protect shareholders
today like Milton Friedman said you
should you have to look at stair
stakeholders anyway it's no longer a big
divide and people are using that radical
transparency to keep watching companies
and just scream out and yell at them and
to yell at journalists when they are
falling short you know my inbox is I
created something called moral money at
the Ft which is our platform that tracks
ESG and sustainability it's a newsletter
and I get you know shed loads of emails
every single week from ngos tracking
what companies are doing and screaming
if they fall short
is um it's made it very complicated but
as you say it's it's a collective effort
that's it's quite interesting it's
become a collective effort that
accountability has become that okay then
so so Jen from your point of view
um you know do you how how are you going
to check that you you've got you know
you've got these ambitious ESG goals how
are you going to be accountable to
yourselves and and do you feel this
pressure from the outside that Julian
was describing
yeah certainly the focus on ESG from
investors from our employees has has
grown what I would say is it's built
into the DNA and culture of common so as
I mentioned at the beginning Cummins
embraced the idea of a stakeholder model
before it was the the thing that
companies thought about and we've
embraced the need to ensure that
everything we do leads to a cleaner
healthier safer environment for decades
uh it started in the 90s with the need
to reduce criteria pollutant from diesel
engines and and you know I've personally
been involved in my entire Cummins
advocating for policy and regulation
that that really drives Innovation and
reducing the environmental impact of of
our products it's the thing that brought
me to Cummins in 2000 after starting my
career working on fuel cells by the way
um and so we have set goals right and
we've worked uh both internally and with
the government to ensure that we're
creating regulation and policy that
advanced those we set in 2006 our first
facility energy and greenhouse gas goal
uh and and and drove towards that and
joined
um at the time the U.S EPA climate
leadership program
our current environmental sustainability
plan which we call Planet 2050 we
published in 2019 that was our second
broad environmental sustainability plan
by the way and how we measure ourselves
is we set specific goals we have
qualitative goals for 2030 uh that are
both focused on our product which is by
far our biggest impact uh on the
environment is through our products and
scope 3 emissions and also on our
facilities and our communities um and so
we've got those those qualitative goals
for 2030 and then we have quantitative
targets for 2050 that are aligned to the
Paris climate Accord and we'll publish
how we're doing against those and we
want to ensure that those ESG measures
drive real impact in a meaningful way
and that you're not just feeding the
monkey and and you know reporting things
that aren't actually uh truly impacting
the environment
great well I'd just like to remind the
audience we're not quite at questions
yet but as you're thinking of questions
as you're going along do uh use the Q a
tab somewhere on your your device or
your browser put your question there put
your name in and where you're from
um and you can be adding those now as
we're as we're going along and we will
get to the questions in just a few
minutes
um but I'd like to come now to a sort of
different aspect of uh the sort of ESG
landscape which I think isn't is sort of
talked about but it's often not talked
about in the same in the same way as the
rest of it and that's the people side of
it right you know and the role of that
corporations have in making sure first
of all that people that individuals are
kind of helped through this transition
um especially their Workforce but also
you need a new skill set right there's a
whole load of things that you know
um Jason was mentioning things like wind
turbines and solar well we don't have
enough wind turbine and solar Engineers
we need to get them from somewhere we
need someone needs to train them and so
I'm interested in in the perspective
from all three of you actually about
um that the responsibility of of the
people side of this which definitely
isn't to do with shareholders I guess
perhaps except in the very long term but
what about who does the training who
takes responsibility for the community
who takes responsibility for helping
people should that be corporations or
should it be somebody else uh Jason
let's come to you first
yeah maybe I'll answer that just by
making a broader observation about sort
of the conversation the last few minutes
and I think it relates to people because
and I'm wondering if Jen and Jillian
disagree it does I think it's important
to note uh that this whole conversation
and the role of corporations in ESG I
wonder if they think it has a
particularly
Western sort of U.S European take to it
and when we look at the challenge of
climate change of course it doesn't
matter where a ton of CO2 emissions come
from they all contribute equally to the
problem the bulk of the growth and
Emissions going forward is from emerging
and developing economies again I gave
that number of three to four trillion
dollars a year of investment in clean
energy
most private most in the emerging and
developing economies that's where the
growth and energy use is
and in those parts of the world I think
the concerns are often uh different and
the motivations of companies are
different because much of the world's
Energy System is dominated by
state-owned Enterprises
and so we often talk in the oil and gas
sector for example about the companies
we've all heard of BP and Exxon and
shell etc those so-called super Majors
make up 15 of the world's oil and gas uh
most of the world's oil gas comes from
National oil companies and state-owned
Enterprises that have different sets of
incentives
um and uh and different excuse me
different challenges when one thinks
about how to move in a lower carbon
direction we around the world we're
talking about Renewables we are still
building new coal plans even if we
stopped building new coal plants if we
operate the existing set of coal plants
to the end of their normal economic life
so they pay back investors that alone
would cause us to exceed our carbon
budget by 2050 and that's just a
function of how big the numbers are what
it takes to meet energy needs and energy
growth for people uh around around the
world so when you talk about the people
involved part of that is people who have
almost nothing and have contributed
almost no emissions uh to date and and
who are looking to consume much larger
amounts of energy for because of the
prosperity and the economic growth that
goes along with that as you said then
when we make that transition
and hopefully produce our energy in
different ways uh uh and with cleaner
forms of clean energy instead of fuels
like coal
um that is economically disruptive to
very significant parts of some
communities uh and and some countries
and so it is important to make sure that
we do a much better job than we have to
date taking seriously what the economic
dislocations look like and I think
there's often
whether it's free trade for the last 30
years or now talking about the energy
transition promises made that you know
winners can compensate losers and don't
worry we can have new retaining programs
and and someone who's worked in the coal
mine can figure out how to do something
else that's that's not we don't have a
great track record of success with that
and I think that we do need much greater
government policy Focus to put real
funding into that in real programs and
then of course the corporate sector uh
and companies are going to have a huge
role to play building the workforce that
they will need Jen knows better than I
do with Cummins needs to make sure that
they can build in a different way moving
forward
well then we have the challenge to the
two of you there so you so so Jillian
and Jen you can pick up on on either
side of that either the more General uh
Workforce and people think all this
International the fact that you know
different countries are arriving in this
space from different places
um and they have different needs um
Julian do you want to go first yeah
absolutely um okay a point of good news
and cheer is that if you slap the word
green on almost any student University
course today
um you will get your attendance
quadruple immediately I mean audit
classes have often been fairly sparsely
attended at Business Schools because
it's like oh gosh go to audit if you're
slapping the words if you put green
audit on a business school class
suddenly everyone enrolls so the good
news is that lots of young people today
do want to train to go into the green
fields
um the bad news is that the pipeline is
slow
um and it's going to take a while for
that to happen and there needs to be a
lot of retraining of people in Middle
careers particularly people who are
working in fossil fuels and need to be
redeployed so that or class and smart
government intervention and public
private partnership and they need to get
a move on
um the bad news has come to a very very
different point about the developing
world the emerging markets and their
needs for Capital Jason's 100 right of
course that in many ways that is a Key
Arena where the debate about how to
decarbonize going forward is critical
because they are carbonizing right now
by building coal plants and other
emission heavy forms of energy and
infrastructure and the one of the most
shameful things that did not happen at
in Egypt or rather it should have
happened it didn't and that shameful was
the failure of the rich Western World to
find more effective ways to channel
money to support the energy transition
in the developing World it doesn't just
mean in terms of giving direct Aid and
Loan direct Aid and Loans although that
should be happening much more the really
really critical component is how are you
going to move all the money in the
private sector trapped in the west to to
the emerging markets and that's very
unlikely to happen unless something
called Blended Finance starts happening
which is basically using government
money to provide an insurance policy for
private sector investors who want to
invest in Risky projects and in most
Emerging Market green projects are risky
this requires coordination for groups
like The World bank and they need to get
move on very very urgently Because
unless that happens the money is not
going to flow and the money doesn't flow
cold clouds will keep being built and
will all fry
um you just reminded me of something
extraordinary I was I met someone at the
weekend who now works in the Renewables
industry in in Norway and they said they
graduated 10 years ago and they told me
that when they graduated the Renewables
companies were only employing people
with oil and gas experience because they
were already trained in something to do
with offshore energy and so he went to
work in the oil and gas
sector for eight years to get enough
experience to go into the Renewables
industry and I thought that was the most
ridiculous thing I had ever heard I'm
hoping it's better now and Jen on the
people then what what's your perspective
on all of this
yeah great well first I just I want to
say uh you know Cummins is a global
company and as I've talked about our
environmental sustainability goals those
do and Compass are our Global business
and we work hard on on regulation and
policy as well as Partnerships uh in our
key markets uh around the world in fact
just last week we signed a member
memorandum of understanding with one of
our key Partners in India Tata uh to
collaborate on xero emissions technology
including hydrogen engines battery
electric and Fuel Cell vehicles but
people is a topic that um I think is
critically important so I'm really glad
that you raised it Helen and
you know the first uh aspect that to me
is so important is how do we actually
create an environment where we're
bringing
diverse perspectives and everybody is
and and helping to solve the challenges
that we're facing in this world and so
there's a lot of focus and comments on
diversity equity and inclusion and
really creating an environment where
we've got big challenges and you know as
a woman who came up through a technical
field
right uh women are in the minority in
engineering and we need to address that
we need to ensure that we're not
excluding parts of our population from
um bringing their their ideas and
perspective to bear on these problems so
that's the first challenge is bring
everybody in we can't leave people on
the sidelines as we're we're tackling
climate change
and then the second is that as the
technology evolves there is a need to to
reskill and Advance
um skills in certain areas I see it as
um
partially a evolving skills that people
have so as a mechanical engineer I came
into Cummins and worked on electronic
engines that had after treatment
chemical systems right our skills evolve
over time and a lot of what we need to
do will be evolving the skills that our
employees have over time and there are
areas where we need to really focus on
advancing capability uh in the
electronic space and the battery space
semiconductors and so we do need to have
a focused effort both in a Collegiate
level as well as professional and
advancing skills and and critical areas
and and that's something that we are
focused on doing
well uh talking of people let's hear
from the people so uh people out in the
audience this is your chance to ask your
questions there is a q a tab somewhere
do put your name and uh where you're
from if you'd like uh it's not required
you can you can uh ask your question
anonymously so do that now we are at
audience questions and so let's start
with
um
a question which I think a lot of people
a lot of people feel and they express it
in different ways which is from uh
Rosario de Dio and the question is um
the economics of energy transition are
complex but not complicated why do you
think the debate is still very polarized
and not evidence driven so I guess the
first part there is is the debate still
polarized and to what degree and then
why is it that the doing bits and the
debate seems to lag behind uh what the
logic perhaps says we should do um Jason
you can start on this
yeah it's a really good question I think
the answer to it's probably different in
different places and I think the the
broad issue you know there there is a
history in in the U.S we should remember
it was
um in the George H.W bush Administration
that a cap and trade system for sulfur
dioxide was put in place for local Air
Pollution that caused acid rain or the
fundamental Landmark laws we have like
the Clean Water Act the Clean Air Act
the Environmental Protection Agency were
created during the administration of
Nixon uh conservation
has had a bipartisan consensus and the
issue of climate change and the energy
transition has become increasingly
polarized I think some politicians are
responsible for using it as a political
wedge I think some companies are
responsible for muddying the waters and
trying to cast out on what is pretty
clear science of of climate change
caused by by the human use largely not
entirely uh human use of of fossil fuels
and also the agriculture uh sector
and um and I think people there are
costs I mean in many ways you may see
improvements where things become more
economic over time but on the whole
there are it's probably more expensive
to make cement and steel in low carbon
ways than not low carbon ways maybe
that'll be different in the future it's
sometimes harder to see the benefits how
do you the Govern U.S the government
just came out with a revised estimate of
what the cost to society is from the
damages of putting a ton of CO2
into the atmosphere so-called social
cost of carbon it can be harder to see
the consequence of inaction and what the
actual cost uh will be to Society of the
impacts of climate change but I think
that's changing too I think people see
each and every day in their lives
whether it's flooding in Pakistan or you
know wildfires across California more
severe heat waves things are changing
things are different and that's going to
unfortunately get worse uh not better
and so I think hopefully there is a
growing sense that climate change is a
problem and you do see that in in
polling and you look um certainly on
both sides of the aisle it's more for
Democrats than Republicans but both are
shifting and it's also true for young
people than older people when you ask
them what is their top concern uh
increasingly climate change is rising to
the top of that list or or near the top
the top few issues
um Julian or Jen do you have a a
contribution on that on the the debate
in the why why it seems to be so hard to
convince to get everyone on board with
doing this um Jillian perhaps
um well you know one simple answer is
turkeys don't vote for Christmas and um
there's an entire fossil fuel industry
out there that's trying to present
preserve its business and to fend off
anything that's going to stop their
business flourishing
um and they've been lobbying a lot and
there's a lot of politicians who are
behold to the fossil fuel industry in
the past so that's a big issue
um but secondly as Jason points out you
know there have been moments in the past
when in fact there was more of a
bipartisan consensus around the need to
act on this if you look back to 1960s
and the era of Rachel Carson and the
Silent Spring movements
um two things were remarkable about that
one was that in that era which as I said
earlier with the mid-20th century when
people looked at government not business
to solve problems in that era the Rachel
Carson activists didn't even bother
trying to talk to corporate leaders
their entire focus on lobbying was
government and unions
um not company owners and investors and
CEOs very striking shift has taken place
in terms of the people we expect to fix
problems in the last 50 years secondly
in those days it really was bipartisan
because it was seen as protection and
preservation which is something which is
quite a naturally conservative value in
particular they were trying to protect
and preserve the national parks
um and there's quite a lot of polling
suggest that if you could change some of
the language around the climate change
discussions now and talk about
stewardship and Environmental Protection
um You probably bring a lot more of the
right wing on board and you could even
tap into the Evangelical vote as well by
talking about stewardship because that's
a very strong concept within the
Christian tradition and so there could
be ways to try and put you know bring
that but unfortunately in the climate
right now it's so pet rise it's simply
the fact that there are so many
progressives arguing for climate change
measures means that you're guaranteed to
get a number of the far right saying no
just on that basis
um Jen do you have a do you have a do
you what do you see in terms of the the
debate and whether people are convinced
or not or convinced to move quickly I
guess I think broadly people recognize
climate change as a real issue
um you know as as Jason pointed out you
only need to read the paper each morning
to see further evidence of the the
impact that's having on the planet on
and on people around the world and and
that is also why with this polarization
and our political system you see growing
pressure on corporations to act
um to do something uh from from the the
public and as we've talked about over
the last 45 minutes policy plays an
important role and so we really do need
to
um in a bipartisan way tackle some of
these issues and in the government as
well the other thing I would say is
while on the one hand I can recognize
climate change as a real issue and
believe that we need to do something
when it comes to my bottom line and do I
want to pay more
to buy a car or to you know to fuel fuel
that vehicle if it's costing me more
then that's a challenge right and so and
with inflation and other pressures
um that that reality is is very much
there you know personally
um
my view is
putting a price on carbon and driving
the most economic way to to address the
issue
um makes a lot of sense and you have to
you have to have a way to do that that
is Equitable
um which is why it you know is is
challenged politically but I do think
that at some point we need to have uh
increasing focus on carbon tax pricing
on carbon in some way to monetize the
impact of CO2
well we've got a nice question that
follows on from that from David korgard
and and in a way this is kind of the
other kind of frustration so
um yes how can companies basically is
asking how how can companies explain to
the public that you can't switch
overnight you know this is a huge
transition and it takes time to work out
what works at scale and how to do it and
how to organize it and I guess you know
from The public's point of view so here
in the UK with the way our electricity
supplies work we can just switch in
principle to another to a renewable
electricity company and we can just you
know press a button online and suddenly
we can pay for renewable electricity
um
and so for the for a consumer it sort of
looks like oh well I should just be able
to choose something different so how and
yet you know the companies behind the
scenes are oh but you can only have
renewable energy if someone's got some
permits and built some wind turbines and
done all this other stuff
how how do we
sort of keep the public enthusiastic
about this change while saying we're not
gonna get there you know we it's going
to take some time or should we just push
the corporations harder Jason what do
you think
well I think if uh if if corporate
leaders want to help improve public
understanding the first thing they
should do is point them to the work of
the center on global energy policy at
Columbia
um everyone can get their plug-in it's
great it's fine and and being I'm being
a little a little facetious but but
obviously you know that is our mission
but obviously many other actors in that
ecosystem to help people understand the
scale and difficulty of this challenge
you know uh we've heard from
Jen about the really extraordinary work
Cummins is doing all around the world
she mentioned Partnerships with tata for
example it's a good example right India
which has about 150 gigawatts of solar
energy has a staggeringly ambitious goal
to get to 500 by 2030. very hard to
achieve if they can achieve it coal use
in India will be higher in 2030 than it
is today because that's how big the math
of our Energy System is that's how big
the numbers are
and if you think about the inflation
reduction act we talked about before and
the assumptions that go into how much
that will reduce emissions it assumes
that these large tax credits bear in
mind you only get the tax credit if the
battery in your car has components that
are have nothing to do with China in
terms of their mining refining
processing that supply chain barely
exists today and then if we are able to
deploy those tax credits EV sales
increase Sevenfold seven times between
now and 2030. and then of course you
need the charging infrastructure and the
grid to support that and the average
vehicle is on the road 12 13 14 years so
it takes time for the energy system to
turn over it takes time for the Capital
stock to turn over and that's a big
problem we have with climate change
because we are um unfortunately running
out of time in terms of the number of
years that are left to start to bring
down emissions consistent with a goal
like Net Zero 2050. so you know two
things can both be true at the same time
one is significant corporate leadership
and commitment moving in clean energy
one is a dramatic growth in clean energy
year on year and Emissions keep going up
and that's been the history of the last
10 15 you know years and so I think just
helping people understand the scale and
magnitude of this challenge you talked
about what an individual consumer in
Europe can can do but of course as a
system
Europe is coping with the cutoff of
Russian gas Often by in the near term
moving to Coal building new LNG import
infrastructure because it's going to
take many years to build out a renewable
electricity system in Europe not to
mention all again all the parts of the
economy that that electricity can't fuel
yet so we need to move much faster to do
those things and and help you know
improve public awareness as much as we
can and bring consumers along
and Jen I imagine you're on the very
much on the sharp end of this because
you know for all the Cummins talks about
these new technologies you are still
making diesel engines so how how do you
deal with the sort of Education thing
for the public here
yeah I spent a lot a lot of time on this
it's you know it is why
um
my view is that diesel does play a role
in decarbonization because we can't wait
right we can't wait and we have to
accelerate zero-based Technologies and
put them in markets where the
infrastructure can exist
where the technology is viable but if
you think about a long-haul truck that's
going across the country there is no
charging infrastructure first and second
of all a range of a heavy duty truck
with a battery is 100 to 200 miles and
these trucks regularly operate three to
four hundred miles
you know in a in a day and so the bottom
line is if we didn't stop selling diesel
engines and only sold battery electric
and Fuel Cell electric which we could we
have those Technologies
customers couldn't use them to run their
business they couldn't buy them they
wouldn't work and so we have to build
this out in a stepwise way and we have
to you know really invest in uh the
infrastructure and advancing the
technology so that we can get there and
then we have to think about how do we
more efficiently use what we have
because that can be a part of solving
this issue too it's really that
efficiency of how we're moving people
and goods well the CO2 emissions from
that well the thing we the thing we
don't that people don't talk about using
less energy is the most efficient thing
of all and and that's that's another
story
um Julian do you see do you see this
sort of tussle between the you know just
do it now and the the speed at which
companies are moving or is that is that
is it just do you think it's happening
at the speed it's happening and everyone
will just deal with it
well I had a lot of sympathy for
companies right now because
um it's certainly the case that there
are companies which are acting in bad
faith and there are companies that are
basically doing green washing and it is
for some companies it is more corporate
um spin than actual reality however
having said all that there are many many
companies who actually are really
exciting to promote the energy
transition
um you know as much reasons as
self-defense as anything else
um but many of them are now caught
between a complete rock and a hard place
because on the one hand if you're a
company operating in America
um you have a whole bunch of Republicans
and a whole bunch of red states that are
actually attacking you for introducing
green measures
um you know it sounds unbelievable for
people sitting in Europe but that is the
reality
um at the same time in Parts other parts
of America the blue States the Democrats
States you've got people attacking you
if you're not moving fast enough
um people everyone knows that America's
you know divided in the states in terms
of the abortion issues and Roby Wade but
it's just as divided if you look at
what's happening in terms of green
policies so a company operating in
America today is kind of in a no-win
situation and just to add to the problem
is if they stand up and talk about what
they're trying to do to be greens
um you know two or three years ago when
I first created moral money at the Ft I
had CEOs queuing around the block to try
and get interviewed to tell me how
brilliant they were and tell me about
their Net Zero pledges and how much they
love Net Zero and we couldn't get enough
of it now you have this extraordinary
thing happening called Green hushing not
green washing but Green hushing in that
CEOs don't want to stick their heads
above the parapet because they'll be
attacked from the right for doing too
much and they'll be attacked from by
activists for doing too little and the
latter is a real issue because if you
stand up and say I've got a NetZero
pledged you then get a whole bunch of
ngos watching you and saying oh well you
haven't quite done what you said
um so it's really really tough and I
totally understand that for what it's
worth I think the media has become more
mature recognize that yes there's green
washing and backsliding but also
recognized it ain't gonna happen
tomorrow and that many companies are on
a journey and trying but it's not easy
and they are caught between a rock and a
hard place and most importantly I think
companies and policy makers have to get
a lot more honest that they are on a
journey and they don't know what what
works and what doesn't they're trying to
rebuild the engine of a plane as they
actually fly it they have to be honest
and say they're going to be mistakes and
above all else everybody has to grow up
and become more honest about trados
because there are going to be trade-offs
trade-offs trade-offs and if anyone
pretends there's a magic wand that's
going to solve all the problems without
trade-offs they are not just living in
Cal cooker land they're lying to
themselves and everyone else and that
means both society and companies and
policy makers have to recognize their
trade-offs embrace them and realize
we're all collectively on a journey
well um let's not have any green let's
not have any green hushing around here
and put Jen on the spot then so
um as the sort of representative of the
corporate world here which you I guess
you are what what specific you know you
did mention some before but you've got
you've got this planet 2050 plan so what
what specific what are you going to put
your neck on the line for I guess you
know do your do your anti-green hushing
thing here
yeah you know I think you have you know
we will stand up and fight for what we
believe is right and you know at the end
of the day it may not always be popular
but it's really focused on doing what's
right for the planet what's right for
our employees our customers and our
investors and we do believe that there's
an intersection of those things
decarbonization and the need to reduce
CO2 emissions
uh is a critical challenge this planet
will not continue to exist if we don't
recognize that reality uh and address
uh climate change
and we believe it's a growth opportunity
for our business so we lean into the
challenge the need to actually
fundamentally change the company and
what we look like you know we speak up
and speak out on the key elements of
policy regulation uh supply chain you
know all of those Talent all of those
issues that are are required to drive
this change I mean we talk we've been
talking about the inflation reduction
act I've you know I and other leaders
Cummins actively advocated for that I
was
um you know in um
event with President Biden in the White
House just before that was signed so
we're not afraid to speak out and I
think companies have to do that right we
have to come to the table with data
um and be transparent about what's
required because these are complicated
issues right there's no Magic's button
that solves them but we got to bring
that and lean into the the challenge
figure out how we really Leverage The
the workforce and the talent that we
have because people are motivated by
this too when I talk about
decarbonization and our strategy to our
employees they get energized
um and we need to tap into that and and
and solve the the problem and get past
um
you know this view that
it's going to be easy or we don't want
to change because it's just critical
critical for for the future
sustainability of our planet
okay well that is a great we all right
we've run out of time but I think
leaving the audience energized is a
great place to finish so um I'd like to
thank all three fabulous contributors uh
Jennifer Ramsey Jillian tet and Jason
bourdoff and of course thank you to the
audience for listening and contributing
your questions uh thank you to
intelligence Squad and coming for
organizing this event if you'd like to
see more of what intelligence Square
does please visit intelligencequad.com
and where you can also watch the
previous two events in this series there
and for more for more information about
Cummings you can visit cummings.com and
that's it for today so lots of food for
thought I hope you get on and do some
thinking let's all make this happen uh
so thank you very much and goodbye